the movie begins in a distant period
where we are introduced to a time
traveling operative who goes by the name
of Andrea Collins she is a team of
intelligence Scholars who have devised a
plan to Traverse time and rectify the
course of events in order to secure
Harmony and peace in the upcoming eras
it turns out that a man by the name of
Adolf Hitler has committed the atrocity
of killing 60 million human beings up to
the present day thus Andrea decides to
embark on a journey back in time to the
early years of Adolf Hitler ants take
necessary actions one of the scholars
cautions her of the dangers associated
with this idea deeming it as a one-way
trip to the Twilight Zone however Andrea
remains undeterred in her Quest she is
willing to risk her own life for the
sake of countless others in the next
scene Andrea in collaboration with her
team develops a meticulous scheme to
infiltrate the residents of Adolf Hitler
in order to accomplish this she poses
her identity as a newly hired housewife
who is entrusted with certain domestic
responsibilities the only problem is
that they have a narrow window of just
48 hours to execute their plan and
eradicate Hitler before the real
housekeeper arrives the stakes are high
and the pressure is intense as Andrea
and her team realize the gravity of
their mission and the consequences of
any misstep or delay nonetheless they
remain determined to see their plan
through knowing that the success could
lead to Major improvements in the future
yeah like there won't be so many movies
about Adolf Hitler anymore after a while
Andrea travels through time and
eventually arrives in brano Austria
where her mission to alter the course of
history commences however the sudden and
abrupt transition Through Time causes
her to feel disoriented and dizzy and
she is forced to puke excessively upon
arrival she must have accidentally said
diagonally as she attempts to steady
herself and regain her composure she is
approached by a beggar who asks if she
has any money Andrea immediately extends
a few coins showing her generous and
charitable nature she then continues on
her journey only to be stopped by a
police officer who demands an
explanation for her presence in the area
however our intelligent protagonist
easily makes up a believable Alibi
allowing her to proceed with her crucial
Mission undetected after walking the
unfamiliar land for a while Andrea
finally arrives at the doorstep of Adolf
Hitler's home there she encounters zalwa
Hitler the father of the infamous
historical figure who is known to be a
strict and overprotective parent
especially when it comes to his precious
Offspring al-wah whose name I might be
mispronouncing but I don't care because
he's Hitler's dad and it's not worth
looking up expresses his surprise at her
early arrival wondering why she has come
two days before her scheduled start date
in a quick thinking maneuver Andrea
pretends to have finished her previous
commitments in a timely manner she also
says that there was no reason to wait
for two extra days as she is in dire
need of money following this brief
exchange alwa hands her a document
outlining her daily duties which
primarily consists of cooking and
cleaning unfortunately she discovers
that she has not been assigned the task
of caring for Baby Hitler which is a
major setback in her plan when she asks
about it alwa introduces her to
Christina who is responsible for taking
care of the baby he then divulges that
he has suffered the tragedy of losing
three of his children in the past and
Adolf is his fourth child therefore he
is determined to take every
precautionary measure to ensure the
safety and well-being of his son alwa
proceeds to blame his wife Clara for the
loss of their children considering her
to be physically and mentally frail at
night Andrea abides her time until
everyone else in the house has fallen
asleep scared but motivated she grabs a
nearby pillow and sets off down the
hallway her gaze fixed on the innocent
sleeping form of baby Adolf Hitler with
each step her grip on the pillow
tightens her mind consumed with thoughts
of the countless lives she could save by
eradicating the source of so much evil
however her scheme is abruptly halted by
the unexpected appearance of Clara who
enters the room just as Andrea is about
to carry out her plan desperate to avoid
detection Andrea quickly stashes the
pillow at the far end of the crib and
adopts a soothing motherly demeanor
pretend that she was merely trying to
calm the fussy baby although a bit
suspicious Clara believes her
explanation and goes to check on her
child it becomes evident that she is
extremely protective of her baby just
then Adolf begins to cry oh shut up you
little Willis prompting Clara to request
that Andrea hold him since she herself
is not permitted to touch the infants as
per al-wah's orders after successfully
lulling the baby back to sleep Andrea
and Clara make their way back to the
quarters only to be disturbed by the
unmistakable sounds of coitus coming
from alwa's bedroom it turns out he is
engaged in a passionate affair with
Christina the babysitter but instead of
getting angry Clara remains unfazed and
simply leaves indicating that she
doesn't care anymore perhaps Andrea
should just kill alwa might actually
solve everything the following morning
as Andrea goes about her duties she
encounters zawa who inquires if she
would like to attend a live performance
with him that evening not wanting to
waste any more time Andrea pretends to
be sick and suggests that AWA take
Christina with him instead through
surprise the man takes up the suggestion
and asks his babysitter if she wants to
go with him Christina agrees without
thinking twice Andrea is relieved that
her plan is still on track and continues
to perform her daily chores while biding
her time until she can carry out her
mission to eliminate Adolf Hitler as a
baby as the evening progresses Christina
approaches Andrea with a request to take
extra care of the baby emphasizing that
alwa would not hesitate to harm her if
anything happens to his child upon
hearing this Andrea inquires if
Christina's decision to sleep with alwa
was a result of her fear of being
executed Christina says no but then
reveals that AWA made a promise to marry
her someday moreover she divulges that
Clara was once a housekeeper like
herself whom AWA had promised to marry
after the death of his first wife all
this information shocks Andrea but she
keeps her thoughts to herself and
continues to focus on the task at hand
in the next scene AWA and Christina
depart for the live performance whereas
Clara falls into a deep sleep due to
exhaustion from the day's activities
this situa gives Andrea the perfect
opportunity to complete her Mission
therefore she stealthily makes her way
into the baby's room and picks up the
blanket however in a shocking turn of
events Andrea finds herself paralyzed
with fear no matter how hard she tries
she just cannot do it Andrea's failure
to kill Baby Hitler leaves her
distressed and searching for a solution
to prevent the future Massacre she turns
to the church and confides in a priest
explaining the dire situation and asking
for guidance however the priest
dismisses her claims stating that no one
can predict the future determined to
prevent the catastrophe Andrea attempts
to convince Clara to flee with the baby
but her efforts are futile now she is
torn between her moral obligations and
the potential consequences of her
actions she doesn't want to kill the
baby but she doesn't want to let him
live either as Andrea wanders the
streets of Bruneau depressed she
encounters zawa who begins to spew
hateful and anti-semitic comments at her
sweet surprisingly this Sparks an idea
and Andrea his mind about how she can
possibly prevent the future atrocities
that she knows are coming I'm telling
you she's just gotta kill alwa in the
same evening alwa Hitler hosts a dinner
party at his home where he entertains
his guests leaving baby Adolf unattended
this situation presents another golden
opportunity for agent Andrea to carry
out her Mission she takes advantage of
the moment and sneaks into the baby's
room where she takes the child and
leaves the house unnoticed her
destination is a nearby River where she
intends to end the life of the baby as
well as her own at the same time alwa
orders Christina to bring the baby to
him but when the babysitter goes there
she is shocked to find that the child is
missing horrified she frantically starts
looking for Adolf and eventually spots
Andrea fleeing with him In Her Arms
Christina gives Chase but Andrea is
already far ahead eventually she finds
Andrea on the edge of the bridge
overlooking the river their eyes meet
once and before Christina can approach
her Andrea takes a deep breath and jumps
into the river with the baby
come baby cries Hitler witnessing the
horrific sight and realizing that Adolf
has been murdered Christina starts going
crazy however just then she comes across
a gypsy woman who is attempting to sell
her own baby this gives her a cunning
idea Christina checks her purse and
exchanges all the money she has for the
Gypsy baby the plan is a risky one but
it is the only solution she can think of
right now following this Christina
returns with the baby to Hitler's guests
and has everyone fooled however alwa
being the father of the baby senses that
something is wrong but despite this he
doesn't react in front of his guests and
decides to wait and see how things
unfold in the final scene the self-host
named Forest Whitaker what reflects on
the story of Andrea Collins and pays
tribute to her by observing a moment of
silence he acknowledges her bravery in
making the ultimate sacrifice for the
betterment of humanity however he notes
that in her quest to prevent the evil
that Adolf Hitler would later become
Andrea inadvertently played a part in
creating the very monster that she
sought to eliminate it turns out the
Gypsy baby grew to become Adolf Hitler
the leader of Nazi Germany who was
responsible for the Holocaust and the
killing of several million innocent
people he also initiated a brutal War
which was the most destructive of its
kind in mankind history with this Forest
Whitaker emphasizes that the passage of
history is unalterable and no matter how
hard one tries they only end up making
things worse even the smallest of
changes in the past can lead to dire
consequences in the future why didn't
they just send another agent back in
time to kill the Gypsy subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching